bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous ses
sens public on est ensemble pour 90
minutes la promesse elle est dans le
titre de l'émission donner du sens à
l'actualité vous proposer à des clés de
compréhension des mutations de notre
société et des enjeux de cette campagne
présidentielle voici le sommaire de ce
1er février l'ambassadeur de france
expulsé du mali un camouflet dont 100
par les opposants du président de la
république faut-il rapatrier les soldats
de l'opération barkan le sel reste-t-il
un foyer de terrorisme islamiste les
réponses de nos experts dans le débats
d'actu juste après ses titres 1 un
nouveau logiciel pour mieux contrôler
les armes et les 5 millions
d'utilisateurs en france qui en
possèdent légalement il entre en vigueur
la semaine prochaine réaction des
passionnés d'armes et des chasseurs
évidemment dans notre rubrique les
électeurs ont la parole et puis un mot
ce soir le hoki sme partie des
etats-unis symbole des combats des
minorités pour leurs droits civiques il
est devenu depuis quelques mois l'objet
de polémiques politiques en france et de
questions au gouvernement au sénat
aujourd'hui sa définition son histoire
ces dérives sont au coeur de notre débat
de société tout à l'heure
mais d'abord donc la situation au mali
le point avec jérôme rabier c'est la
dernière étape de la crise diplomatique
entre la france et le mali la junte
militaire au pouvoir à bamako a sommé
l'ambassadeur français de quitter le
pays une sanction justifiée par le
ministre des affaires étrangères malien
la france est le seul pays dans cette
poursuivre d'attac intellect contrôler
la légalité et la légitimité des
autorités de la transition
la tension est en effet à son comble
alors que la junte s'était engagé à
organiser des élections elle a annoncé
sa volonté de rester cinq ans de plus au
pouvoir
inacceptable pour la france et ce n'est
pas un événement du à l'irresponsabilité
je rêvais des terres mémo du ahly
légitimité d'un gouvernement de coup
d'état qui va nous faire enrayer notre
lutte contre le terrorisme la confiance
est également rompus sur le plan
militaire alors que les forces
françaises sont engagées dans le pays
pour lutter contre les groupes
terroristes au sahel la junte a fait
appel à des mercenaires russes du groupe
wagner connus pour leur proximité avec
le pouvoir russe mais difficile pour la
france de retirer ses troupes alors que
des groupes terroristes aux pertes
encore dans la région on intervient sur
place avec d'autres pays européens avec
l'onu et j'ai donné un calendrier c'est
à dire d'ici à la mi février on va
travailler on prévoir une adaptation ce
qui est certain c'est que va continuer à
lutter contre le terrorisme au sahel la
france qui avait déjà réduit sa présence
compter sur un roe déploiement des
forces dans le cadre de l'opération
takouba avec une quinzaine de pays
européens mais les tensions des
dernières semaines remettent en cause
tout le dispositif antiterroriste dans
la région neuf ans après le déploiement
de l'armée française pour enrayer la
progression de groupe djihadiste au mali
et pour comprendre ce qui se passe au
mali et au sahel
je vous présente mes invités n'égale et
bagayoko bonjour bienvenue vous êtes
politologue président du think tank
african security secteur network
christian cambon bonsoir bonsoir
sénateurs l ère du val de marne
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées
antoine glaser bonsoir vous et soit
journaliste et écrivain spécialiste de
l'afrique vous avez publié vous publiez
le piège africains de macron du
continent à l'hexagone c'est aux
éditions fayard on est également en
duplex en visioconférence avec le
général jerome e pellistrandi bonsoir
n'ya que vous êtes rédacteur en chef de
la revue défense nationale
et puis mes côtés laetitia cru pas
éditorialiste politique bonsoir laetitia
mes côtés tous les mardis tous les
jeudis dans ce sens public je voudrais
commencer ce débat en rendant hommage
aux militaires français notamment aux 53
soldats qui sont morts au sahel dont 48
au mali et pensez aussi à leurs familles
je voulais démarrer comme ça et
finalement ça me mène forcément à la
première question ce débat pourquoi sont
ils morts qu'ici encore bon pour nous
protéger du terrorisme
pourquoi sont ils morts c'est une vraie
question que nous devons nous poser avec
peut-être d'autant plus d'acuité faut
pas oublier non plus les blessés sont
des centaines de blessés et certains
excessivement grave il faut qu'ils ne
soient pas morts pour rien nous avons
quand même le souvenir de ce qui s'est
passé en afghanistan où des familles se
souviennent de ce qui s'est passé à
uzbeen on a oublié déjà et il faudrait
faire en sorte que ces femmes et ces
hommes qui ont donné leur vie
ceux qui aujourd'hui même sont toujours
en mission ce qui chaque matin partent
en mission sans savoir s'ils reviendront
le soir et bien ne fasse pas ce ne
consentent pas à cet effort et à ce
sacrifice pour rien donc c'est la
question qui se pose maintenant et les
le sens on n'a pas la réponse alors que
ça fait quoi huit ans qu'on est là bas
quel est le sens de notre présent si
nous envoyons nos soldats nous les
exposons dans leur vie contre la volonté
d'une junte mais c'est quand même
l'autorité qui gouvernent actuellement
au mali c'est la question qui se pose et
qui nécessite de mon point de vue une
évaluation sérieuse le sénat le
parlement d'une énergie là a soutenu cet
effort depuis plus de huit ans en votant
les budgets et en donnant les
autorisations nécessaires notamment au
bout des fameux quatre mois lorsque
cette autorisation nous a été demandé
nous étions sûrs de notre bon droit mais
une présence étrangère même si elle est
censée être amis ne peut demeurer que si
le gouvernement en place l'accès et la
tolèrent et la souhaitent tel n'est plus
le cas et la liste indre et semblable
des humiliations qui nous sont adressées
doit nous faire réfléchir
niane bagayoko plus plus le temps passe
plus que cette question elle elle se
pose évidemment
cette question se pose depuis le début
en f1 parce que peut-on considérer que
la lutte contre le terrorisme est un
objectif
quand vous discutez avec des militaires
ils vous expliquent qu'on ne lutte pas
contre un mode opérationnel on lutte
contre un ennemi et cet ennemi un
programme politique social économique
éducatif donc il faut absolument que
l'instrument militaires s'inscrivent
dans un agenda d'une réponse politique à
ce que brandit effectivement cet ennemi
pour la question et si on n'avait rien
fait le bail il mais il ne fallait
absolument pas renoncé à intervenir mais
les conditions d'intervention de
l'opération barca ne sont absolument pas
les mêmes que celles de l'opération
serval dont les objectifs politiques
justement était extrêmement claires et
opérationnelles également il s'agissait
de reconquérir des villes qui avait été
conquise par une coalition rebelle et
djihadistes aujourd'hui le mandat de
l'opération est extrêmement large il
s'étend une sur cinq pays même s'il est
essentiellement concentrée dans la zone
des trois frontières entre le burkina
faso le niger et le mali mais on
s'aperçoit bien que ce qui manque
aujourd'hui et on voit très bien la
réponse de monsieur cambon c'est la
définition du sens de cette intervention
et de ce sacrifice effectivement le quai
consentis par la france et des
partenaires internationaux et par les
forces nationales le renvoi de notre
ambassadeur en tongs laser par cette
junte au pouvoir au mali c'est la
démonstration du piège que vous décrivez
dans votre livre oui enfin c'était
c'était
c'est vrai c'est vrai que finalement la
junte a poussé la france dans le piège
ça veut dire apathie moment où la france
dijon veut plus être en première ligne
on veut européaniser on a créé takouba
exprès pour les forces spéciales et se
retrouver constamment en première ligne
et quand vous voyez nos partenaires
européens ils vous disent bien sûr et
moulis bas nous on est content la france
et la sécurité pendant ce temps on fait
le business parce que la réalité c'est
que finalement cette présence de l'armée
française ça sert vraiment de cache
misère à une présence française qui perd
ses parts de marché et qui en déshérence
sur le continent donc on a l'impression
qu'on est dans une période historique
pour les jeunes africains comme si on
était toujours dans la guerre froide la
france afrique etc et puis en même temps
l'afrique c'est totalement mondialisé on
parle de la chine voyez la russie
maintenant vers les villes et on voit
que finalement la france l'armée
française est d'autant plus e hors sol
quelque part que les djihadistes ont
déjà gagné ils ont fait fuir tous les
occidentaux depuis la mauritanie
jusqu'au soudan ça veut dire tout ce
qu'ils avaient les relations franco
africaines la coopération décentralisée
les ong des mises n oubliez de
coopérants et il ya même plus de rôle mm
au niveau du renseignement humain dont
on se rend pas compte qu'on est dans une
pour moi je pense qu'on est dans une
nouvelle période historique avec des
gens qui vont maintenant s'affirmer
c'est très étonnant c'est comme si la
fin la guerre froide celle du mur du
berlin tout le monde l'a vu avec la
réunification de l'allemagne mais en
afrique c'est comme si on n'avait pas vu
que l'afrique se mondialise et qu'on se
comprend on s'est cru quand même très
longtemps encore chez nous dans tous ces
pays et finalement c'est le retour vers
le col et côte ça veut dire la côte
d'ivoire où il ya une grosse base
militaire française et et toute cette
zone sahélo saharienne très honnêtement
c'est plus à la sepa sepa la france et
les partenaires européens est ce que
vous avez entendu nous avons entendu
vous des jeux parle pas de ce partage
des maurels le chef de l'union africaine
mais d'union européenne
mais est ce que vous avez entendu la
diplomatie diplomatie est ce que vous
avez entendu des politiques européens
des hommes politiques se prononcer sur
ce qui se passe dans le sage c'est comme
si ce n'était pas leur problème le
visitent alliant les espagnols les
allemands veulent où ils entendaient
mais c'est ça la question est ce que
c'est un problème de l'occident le ce
qui se passe au sahel est ce que c'est
le problème alors il ya un truc très
précis ça veut dire la france est
intervenue et location serval c'est une
opération très précises pour empêcher
les djihadistes à l'appel de dieu du
coup nos travaux et un président de
transition mais qui avait quand même
appelé la france à intervenir
rappelez-vous françois hollande qui
disait c'est le plus beau jour de ma vie
politique mais il aurait fallu enfin
c'est ce que lisent et militaires moi je
suis pas spécialiste de l'armée mais ils
disent il aurait fallu ensuite ne pas
avoir une sorte de de présence armée
française un peu à l'ancienne un peu la
guerre froide et autres qui se fait
caillasser il est qu'on voit se font
caillasser cetera il aurait fallu tout
de suite passé ce que la france veut
faire maintenant non seulement heureux
le réaliser mais passer à des forces
spéciales faire vraiment de la lutte
contre le terrorisme mais là vous avez
pu les qu'il ya plus que les capitales
qui tiennent de l'ensemble des espaces
fait rosser les djihadistes qui se
baladent cpcu c'est
la question que thomas posé en début de
plateau personnes et a répondu est ce
que on agit on intervient au mali et
dans les pays africains pour éviter
qu'on ne frappe la france qu'un
terroriste donc
plus tard dans le débat rencontre on y
reviendra un peu après mais merci de
prendre le relais mais on y reviendra
c'est vraiment un chapitre du débat je
voudrais donner la parole aux au général
police tandis sur la situation
militaire est ce que parce que là on est
on est en train de bosser quand même un
portrait diplomatique globalement
négative de ce qui se passe au mali et
au sel depuis plusieurs années mais
militairement quel bilan vous faites
vous
à cette langue de succès tactiques et ce
qui est assez intéressant c'est que là
encore même la semaine dernière du côté
du burkina faso nous avons neutralisé
avec les forces du burkina à ce nombre
de groupes terroristes au plus une
centaine de terroristes la problématique
et c'est ce que les militaires ont
toujours répété la solution est d'ordre
politique l'outil militaire est au
service d'un de la politique et
aujourd'hui on voit bien que malgré les
succès tactique que nous avons sur une
zone extrêmement importante 1 qui
s'étend sur plusieurs milliers de
kilomètres
eh bien cela ne suffit pas parce que il
n'ya pas la volonté politique et en
particulier de certains états de
contrôler et de reconstruire l'état et
c'est bien ça la problématique c'est que
la france doit assumer une charge
qu'elle n'est pas en mesure d'assumer
dans sa totalité et qui d'ailleurs n'est
pas de sa responsabilité
rétablir la souveraineté les
institutions d'un état ça appartient
bien aux autorités maliennes et on voit
bien aujourd'hui et bien ce le clash qui
existe entre l'autorité politique
malienne et les autorités françaises
mais aussi des autres partenaires
africains et européens dans la région il
faut partir tout simplement c'est la
question
le noël du débat la france en deux
parties on ne peut pas partir dans ces
conditions ce serait la double
humiliation
encore une fois la mémoire de nos
soldats est là pour nous dire que leur
sacrifice ne peut pas rester vains ce
que ce qui explique du reste léger
incendie et nous sommes tout à fait
d'accord c'est que il n'ya jamais de
victoire militaire dans ce genre
d'affaires il ne peut y avoir qu'une
réconciliation politique encore faut-il
que les gouvernements locaux acceptent
de respecter les engagements qui sont
les leurs car effectivement la situation
a considérablement changé depuis
l'opération servat mais je rappelle
qu'il ya eu les accords d'alger il y
avait des engagements qui avaient été
pris y compris par le gouvernement
central or nous avons la preuve et moi
j'ai entendu deux hauts responsables
politiques nous dire par exemple ne vous
occupez pas du nord laissez-les est
tombée est-ce qu'un chef d'état peut
tenir un tel langage en disant cette
partie de mon pays ne m'intéresse pas
laissez la faire parce que bien
évidemment il y avait des collusions que
que que tout le monde comprenait et je
pense que malheureusement entre des
autorités du nord du pays et les
djihadistes et des djihadistes et des
groupements armés il ya vous savez la
situation est d'une complexité le
général de gaulle l'avait dit à l'époque
bien avant nous tous et je pense
qu'effectivement il n'y a plus d'état
dans une très grande partie du mali il
n'y a plus d'école il n'y a plus de
dispensaires il n'y a plus de justice il
n'y a plus de police sauf qu'à chaque
fois que les djihadistes prennent en
main et qu'on caire un village il
réinstalle des séries sauf que ces
services là deviennent un peu islamistes
et même beaucoup notamment sur les
écoles et donc à partir du moment où le
pouvoir central ne s'occupe pas des
intérêts de son pays il ya plus de sous
préfet il ya plus de commandant de serre
qui a pu toute cette infrastructure qui
fait qu'un état même africain quand il
fonctionne avec difficulté est quand
même présent on le voit dans d'autres
pays ça fonctionne ailleurs et bien là
il n'y a plus d'état et donc
effectivement la france ne peut pas
assumer et les missions civiles et les
missions militaires je pense que de
surcroît nous devrions aussi regarder de
près comment tout l'argent de l'aide au
développement a pu être dépensés car ce
sont des milliards un délai qui ont
abouti par exemple au bassin du fleuve
niger quand on voit les images puisqu'on
ne peut plus y aller je m'interroge sur
l'endroit où cet argent est passé alors
tiens justement sur sur sur cet aspect
là je vous propose d'entendre parce que
forcément avec l'expulsion de
l'ambassadeur ça devient un enjeu de la
campagne présidentielle les opposants
emmanuel macron sans ça on en parle
valérie pécresse qui a parlé d'
humiliation marine le pen également qui
a pointé la question de l'argent dépensé
là on écoute la candidate du
rassemblement national
et bagayoko ça représente quoi les
données le moment
de la france pour le magnet fectivement
on parle de milliards d'euros sans bien
savoir où ils sont passés massif mais il
est très difficile de chiffrer dans la
mesure où une grande partie passe
également par les canaux de l'union
européenne ne peut pas uniquement la
considérer d'un point de vue national et
je pense aujourd'hui que l'échec en
effet qui est indéniable ne doit pas
simplement être considéré comme un échec
militaire mais comme un échec collectif
d'un type d'intervention qui a failli en
afghanistan mais qui en réalité si on le
regarde sur la durée historique a failli
depuis la guerre du vietnam c'est à dire
que ces approches très standardisé qui
ne se produisent pas avec une
connaissance du contexte local vous
parliez de cette complexité il y a eu
malheureusement un grand nombre
d'erreurs qui ont été commises avec des
alliances qu'on était passé justement
avec certains groupes touaregs y compris
sur le terrain par l'armée française il
faut comprendre quand le premier
ministre malien aujourd'hui accusent la
france de collusion avec les terroristes
il s'agisse il s'adresse avant tout à
son opinion locale et il parle de cette
alliance française avec ceux qui sont
considérés comme les traîtres c'est à
dire les indépendantistes touareg qu'on
fait alliance avec les islamistes
ce que je voulais ajouter il me semble
que la question aujourd'hui n'est pas
tellement de savoir si la france va
rester au sahel la question est vraiment
de savoir si les populations sahéliennes
vont accepter qu'elle y reste parce
qu'effectivement il ya aujourd'hui une
grande difficulté politico diplomatique
avec la junte malienne mais qui peut
être réglé même si la relation était
vraiment dégueulasse dégradé par des
canaux à ses traditions la population
locale aujourd'hui mais je pense qu'il
faut ce matin sur rtl une grand reporter
qui était de retour du mali qui dit que
c'était c'est très vrai dans la capitale
mais c'était pas forcément vrai dans les
villes comme gao tombouctou la houle où
l'armée française est présent tout ça se
passait plutôt bien oui mais même
l'armée française pour pour être allé
dans le rouge est dans le rouge est
difficile pour ces populations
d'interagir avec l'armée française parce
que elles sont immédiatement ciblées et
menacé d'élimination
mais ce dont il faut se rendre compte
c'est qu'il y a aujourd'hui et on aurait
tort de considérer que les opinions
publiques sont uniquement
instrumentalisés soit par des
gouvernements nationaliste soit par des
puissances étrangères il y est
aujourd'hui une réelle déception qui se
transforme en exaspération qui se sentir
et anti français et anti
français et anti politique étrangère de
la france c'est à dire qu'un français
sincèrement dans ces pays là n'est pas
prise à partie n'est pas en danger en
tant que tel les médias français sont
très ciblées qu'il s'agisse de rfi qu'il
s'agisse de france 24 mais aujourd'hui
les populations de ces zones estime
qu'en termes de sécurité individuelle et
collective ne vois pas de retombée au
contraire leur situation s'aggrave et
donc elle ne voit pas l'intérêt d'une
prolongation de cette présence alors je
vais poser la question générale
pellistrandi effectivement est ce que
dans les dons dans les villes où l'armée
française est la plus présente est ce
qu'il ya un sentiment anti présence
française qui était très fort qu'ait
vécues par les soldats quotidiennement
on parlait de caillassages alors là
comme ce que ce qui a été dit il faut
distinguer ce qui se passe à bamako dans
la capitale et ce qui se passe dans
d'autres territoires autour de gao ou
ailleurs c'est bien ça d'ailleurs toute
l'ambiguïté c'est à dire que la la
présence militaire française au
quotidien avec les patrouilles l'aide
médicale et peu ce qui se fait est
relativement bien accepté là mais la
difficulté c'est que nous assumons un
certain nombre de fonctions qui ne sont
pas du ressort de la force armée
reconstruire un système éducatif
reconstruire une police assuré cette
sécurité et c'est bien là le problème il
faut pas oublier que la zone à contrôler
est particulièrement importante est que
nous souhaitons nous avons entamé
justement la diminution de notre
empreinte au sol considérant que ce
n'est pas de notre ressort et donc il
faut poursuivre la lutte contre ces
groupes terroristes tout en essayant de
trouver des modes d'action qui permet de
redonner de la confiance aux populations
locales et c'est bien de la
responsabilité des autorités nationales
que ce soit celle du magny celle du
burkina auchel du niger l'éthicien bout
de la junte et on peut parler d'
éléments de langage avec ce gouvernement
de transition a bien compris qu'il
allait durer en fait c'est un élément de
langage africain alors je voulais mettre
un peu de sourire mais il ya quand même
du sérieux dans cette remarque c'est à
dire que quand on regarde le mali par
exemple mais aussi le tchad la guinée le
burkina faso ce sont des colonels qui
prennent le pouvoir de la raison voilà
assez voilà violente avec les armes ça
s'appelle un putsch ça s'appelle un coup
d'état et ensuite il installe tous un
gouvernement de transition alors de
transition vers quel régime ce n'est pas
défini quelle est la durée quels sont
les délimitations institutionnels rien
n'est défini ça permet simplement à
cette junte de conserver le pouvoir sans
en définir l'exercice voilà c'est une
remarque que je fais parce que nous
sommes nous depuis la france observateur
de ce gouvernement de transition qui est
fait à mon avis justement à destination
de nos populations occidentales pour
peut-être rassuré parce que nous dans
transition on entend
démocratie transition démocratique parce
que c'est notre logiciel c'est notre
culture mais on ne sait absolument pas
vers quoi dans quel régime c est à ce
dirigeant et antoine glaser
si on essaye de brosser un peu le
portrait de ce nouveau pouvoir au mali
quel est son attitude est ce qu'il ya
une stratégie vis-à-vis des jihadistes
si oui laquelle ils ont à mon avis la
stratégie vis-à-vis des djihadistes elle
sera d une stratégie de réconciliation
vous avez actuellement des touareg qui
sont partis ce week-end en italie aya
négociations sera jamais avec la france
a sera peut-être avec d'autres pays
européens et en fait pour eux ils disent
voilà il ya un monsieur en fait le chef
actuellement vraiment du jihad dans
toute la région et sa pléiade khalid ali
c'est le chef du groupe de soutien
l'islam et aux musulmans
c'est lui qui a réussi à fédérer les
anciens algérien d'al qaïda du maghreb
islamique ainsi un du gia gspc dont les
algériens sont débarrassés qu'on
commence à arriver au nord du mali la
france a aussi imploser la libye donc
évidemment les touareg sont rentrés avec
ça les bâtards mes bagages donc il ya
l'alliance il voulait l'indépendance de
l'azawad ans à la fois en même temps
qu'ils se sont dit à dix et avec ils se
sont alliés et donc c'est eux maintenant
qu'ils sont fédérées avec les peuls qui
sont au nord du maine ou au centre du
mali pardon d'un monsieur qui s'appelle
qui est le front de libération du du
macina et donc vous avez une sorte
d'alliance et ce monsieur c'est avec lui
qui vont négocier c'est lui d'ailleurs
qui clique a tué nos confrères ghislaine
dupont et et claude verlon 3 novembre
2013 à kidal mais c'est lui l'homme fort
mais c'est avec lui qui va à zéro c'est
lui rappelez vous quand la libération de
sophie petrona aussi des prêtres
italiens et puis de monsieur soumaïla
cissé le chef du haut pays sont
maintenant malheureusement qui est
décédé c'est lui ça veut dire s'est il
ya ça va se négocier et du coup la
france qui a eu quand même ses soldats
cinquante-cinq soldats qui sont tués
c'est vrai que là il ya une vraie
divergence ça veut dire que la france
veut elle considère qu'il ya de rallier
du sang français sur les mains dont on
doit absolument pas n'est que le
gouvernement qui négocie et la france
n'a pas les moyens encore une fois la
france est seule elle n'a plus ce réseau
qui avait auparavant de toute cette
période de guerre froide où elle était
vraiment effectivement chez elle peu
cynique history particulière et les
jeunes africains ont fait c'est pour ça
que je parle d'un acronis me story qu'on
a l'impression qu'on est encore dans
cette période alors que la france est
isolée elle veut être moins visibles etc
et c'est comme ça que c'est john qui
sont la plupart d'entre eux s'assoient
le président assis meego iter actuelle
me disait la défense etc ils ont été
formés en russie et eux ils se disent on
parle pour moi wagner ça sert de leurre
si
ça pour dire que de la junte actuelle
est tout à fait prête à négocier avec
les djihadistes malien s'ils sont
maliens qu'à gori me permets de pardon
d'ajouter un élément c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on considère que le
différend franco malien est dû au fait
qu'il ait une junte au pouvoir c'est
totalement faux le différend franco
malien commence dès l'époque du sommet
de pô juste après le dialogue national
inclusif c'est à dire des assises qui
décide de manière très collégial qu'il
faut négocier en effet avec l'ia des
galeries qui entre parenthèses à était
intermédiaire avec les otages dans les
années 2000 et la france s'y oppose à ce
moment là donc déjà ce qu'on peut
comprendre ce que c'est juste mais
l'écouté acceptable
malik a du sens mais moi sur les mains
fait d'accord il faut quand même et
raisonnable tu second par rapport au
seuil de ses 53 français qui sont
décédés on est tout à fait d'accord mais
je dis simplement que becca à l'époque
le premier ministre bogota juan
également voulait négocier donc je pense
qu'il ya un profond désaccord entre les
maliens et les français qui ne vient pas
uniquement de la junte malheureusement
voilà je te contredire je pense
effectivement que du temps déjà dit bk
ll y avait des négociations en sous main
d'autre part on parle peu d'un acteur
quand même qu'ils auraient pu jouer un
rôle essentiel qui est l'algérie je
rappelle qu'ils avaient les accords
d'alger qui avait des engagements qui
avaient été pris moi je pense
personnellement que ce grand pays ami
n'est pas mécontent de voir les ennuis
qui arrivait à la france car jamais
notre présence au mali n'a été bien
supporté de la part des algériens et je
le crois sincère je vais je vais
reprendre la main pardon de vous
intéresser parce que je me mets à la
place de nos téléspectateurs qui
peut-être qu'effectivement je reprends
ce que disaient les tice appsteur là la
seule question où la question centrale
de ce débat c'est est ce que ça augmente
le risque terroriste dans notre pays je
sais pas s'il est vrai que les allées
sont répondre à cette question
la vérité oblige de dire que les
attentats qui ont été commis en europe
n'ont jamais été conçus dans cette
région du monde vrai ça a été conçu à
jaca ça a été conçu en irak en syrie
tout ça est bien documenté bien ceci
posé je pense que le risque pour un pays
comme la france et l'europe en général
c'est une déstabilisation générale de ce
continent ou d'une partie très
importante de ce continent du reste on
le voit bien le mouvement djihadiste est
en train de se transporter vers la
guinée le le burkina faso qui détaille
le burkina faso qui était un pays qui
marchait bien moi j'ai connu le burkina
faso qui était vraiment gouverner on
voit les dangers sur la côte d'ivoire et
là on touche des intérêts qui risque de
déstabiliser l'afrique et s'il ya une
déstabilisation de l'afrique là l'europe
peut effectivement avoir peur à la fois
par les flux migratoires par les
intérêts économiques par la stratégie
qui brusquement va changer de nature
antoine glaser
parce que les attentats précédents n'ont
pas été fomentés dans cette région du
monde que ça ne pourrait leur arriver
exactement quand une nature de ces
groupes armés
djihadistes rallye c'est vraiment
locales ces régionales c'est simple si
cédric du rallye historique c'est
simplement que toute cette région en
fait ils ont les capitales ont abandonné
complètement tous les espaces ruraux et
c'est du business mon papa à mes idées
tous sont les cdac de ces la région de
tous les trafics et si cette région
effectivement s'ils descendent vers les
côtes s'ils descendent vers la côte
d'ivoire qui est en train de se
bunkériser est le sénégalais haute c'est
vrai que la déstabilisation de
l'ensemble de cette région ne serait-ce
que les trafics en tous genres ça peut à
terme évidemment ça va être une pression
sur l'europe mais actuellement il n'ya
pas y'a pas on peut pas de citer un
maillot
de préparer un attentat
qui me permettent alors du côté du des
groupes affiliés à al qaïda le discours
est très clair ils disent nous ne
voulons pas attaquer le territoire
français nous voulons que les troupes
étrangères quittent notre sol et nous
laisse vivre selon notre mode de vie
notamment selon la charia mais il ya
quand même eu un incident en france 1
qui s'est produit c'est l'attentât de
colombes qui a été mené à la voiture
bélier et ce terroriste s'est réclamé
dabo walid al sahraouis à l'époque qui a
depuis été éliminé par l'armée française
donc moi je suis comme la plupart des
interlocuteurs très sceptiques quant à
la réalité
actuelle d'une menace mais il ne faut
pas mésestimer le fait qu'il y a eu
quand même un incident de cette nature
il faut regarder regardons quand même un
instant où sont les pays quels sont les
pays qui bordent le nord du mali il faut
toujours regarder la carte vous avez la
libye qui est dans une situation d'état
failli vous avez la tunisie qui connaît
quand même de très grandes difficultés
l'algérie qui en connaît aussi même le
maroc n'est pas à l'abri et la
mauritanie donc il faut bien comprendre
moi souvent nous dit mais que ce que les
français qu'est ce que vous faites au
mali c'est souvent une question qu'on a
sur les réseaux j'ai commencé or si on
regarde la carte on voit bien que si un
état failli un état un califat un état
terroriste 16 s'installer à bamako c'est
le nord de l'afrique et donc c'est les
pays du maghreb je rappelle que c'est
juste la frontière sud de toulon de nice
et de marseille de l'espagne et de
l'italie et on pourrait aussi rajouter
que si le maroc et l'algérie s'entendait
ça fait longtemps que ça sera utile et
non pas la france est présente alors
j'ai demandé à mario vivre 2
me rejoindre sur ce plateau bonsoir ça
marion la politique gouvernementale
évidemment et
à l'extérieur de nos frontières et
notamment au sahel elle est
suivi de près ici au sénat oui depuis le
début de l'opération en barkan le sénat
via la commission des affaires
étrangères et de la défense que vous
présidez monsieur cambon suit de près
les orientations prises par le
gouvernement que ce soit en termes de
stratégie ou de budget et sollicitent
parfois également des débats dans
l'hémicycle c'était le cas le 8 février
2021 pour évoquer justement le bilan et
les perspectives de l'opération barkan
le ministre des affaires étrangères la
ministre des armées sont venus répondre
aux questions des sénateurs qui étaient
nombreuses puisque c'était seulement le
deuxième débat organisé au parlement
depuis le début de l'opération il y a
huit ans et l'année dernière à cette
occasion christian cambon vous alerter
sur la nécessité de consolider les
acquis la force barca mais non elle a
sacrifié avec je vous cite une aide au
développement nécessaires pour éviter
que l'armée française ne soit perçu
comme une force d'occupation
et je vous propose d'écouter une partie
de la réponse que vous avez adressé la
ministre florence parly
le président de la république a donc
convoqué un sommet avec l'ensemble de
nos alliés et de nos partenaires pour
revoir notre stratégie commune et pour
s'assurer que la présence des armées
françaises au sahel était bien voulu et
n'ont pas subi
de ce sommet je crois pouvoir dire que
nous sommes sortis plus forts et plus
nombreux un optimisme qui n'est plus
vraiment de mise aujourd'hui évidemment
au delà de ces séances dans l'hémicycle
il ya eu également des auditions ah oui
est devant la montée des tensions à la
fois au sahel mais aussi à la frontière
entre la russie et l'ukraine
la commission a prévu d'entendre lui
février prochain florence parly l 16
février jean yves le drian il s'agit ici
de répondre à une actualité brûlante
mais d'autres acteurs sont également
régulièrement entendu des responsables
d'organisations internationales des
experts des militaires et le 11 octobre
2021 c'est le chef d'état major des
armées qui était auditionné et sur la
force barque anomalie il identifiait un
point d'inquiétude qui trouve écho
aujourd'hui je le cite à mes yeux la
vraie préoccupation est plutôt
l'évolution de la relation franco
malienne l'arrivée possible de la
société wagner au mali illustre
l'influencé croissante de certains me
compétiteurs dans cette région comme
cela à des jets et a déjà été le cas en
république centrafricaine et justement
pour bien saisir la réalité de terrain à
laquelle sont notamment confrontés à les
militaires les sénateurs de la
commission se déplace une mission
d'information est ainsi prévu cette
année normalement dans les pays du golfe
de guinée pour comprendre comment la
situation délétère au sel les impacts et
puis un autre voyage est normalement
également prévue au mali au niger et au
tchad cette année le dernier remonte à
il ya trois ans christian cambon est ce
que vous avez bon espoir d'y aller et si
oui qu'en attendez vous depuis ce qui
s'est passé la semaine dernière à savoir
les tirs de mortiers sur le camp de gao
que je connais pour y avoir été
plusieurs reprises nous avons quand même
quelques inquiétudes à monter une
mission
néanmoins
nous allons tout de même programmé cette
mission qui peut-être s'arrêtera à
n'djamena ou au niger parce que on va
peut-être parler du de la suite c'est à
dire qu'est ce qui va se passer s'ils
occupent le mali de proches de loin il
va bien falloir trouver une solution
puisque le président de la république
dit on va rester au sahel au sahel il ya
peu il ya le mali puis il ya des pays
voisins ça pose du reste un certain
nombre de questions sur lequel on pourra
dire un mot mais le rôle de la
commission des affaires étrangères et de
la défense est effectivement de valider
toutes les hypothèses et les scénarios
de mains moi je m'interrogerais le
premier ministre ou aux questions au
gouvernement sur ce sujet c'est à dire
c'est quoi les faits c'est quoi les
scénarios que vous avez devant vous on
n'est pas on ne va pas réagir comme ça
alors on peut peut-être envoyer
l'ambassadeur du mali en février le fond
de la leçon de la sphère mérite une
évaluation plus profond qu'est ce qu'on
va faire comment cela va évoluer a aidé
ou va-t-on agir ce qui n'est pas si
facile alors à toi là répond un élément
sur la stratégie évoquée par le
président la république lui-même s'était
dit jeu dernier transformation profonde
de la présence militaire française au
cerveau laisse les termes qu'il avait
employé l'écoutent nous allons seront
une transformation profonde de notre
présence militaire au sahel cette
transformation
se traduira par un changement de modèle
il impliquera le passage à un nouveau
cadre
c'est à dire la fin de l'opération
barkan en tant qu'opération extérieur
pour permettre une opération d'appui de
soutien et de coopération aux armées des
pays de la région qui le souhaitent et
de la mise en oeuvre
d'une opération militaire et d'une
alliance internationale associant les
états de la région et tous nos
partenaires
strictement concentrer sur la lutte
contre le terrorisme général
pellistrandi là la france se donne
quinze jours pour décider de sa présence
maintenir ou pas et sous quelles formes
sa présence militaire au mali qu'est ce
qui peut se passer un redéploiement dans
dans d'autres pays de la région quand
faut-il qu'ils l'acceptent comment vous
imaginez la suite alors il faut déjà
bien comprendre que l'opération marque
anne s'étale sur plusieurs pays donc on
a parlé bien entendu du mali il ya le
niger le tchad et le burkina faso nous
avons déjà entamé un processus de
réduction de la présence militaire
française notamment au mali nous avons
restitué trois bases dans le nord est
qui ont été rétrocédés aux forces armées
maliennes donc de très bonnes conditions
et donc l'idée est de effectivement de
répartir de diminuer nos forces
notamment autour de gao il nous avons
d'autres partenaires il ya bien sûr
niamey pour enfin se concentrer comme
l'avait dit le président de la
république l'été dernier sur la lutte
antiterroriste donc c'est craquer six
groupes terroristes et bien entendu le
faire avec nos partenaires africains
c'est ce qui s'est passé la semaine
dernière au burkina faso où les forces
burkinabaise ont neutralisé une centaine
de terroristes et avec nos partenaires
européens lors se pose bien entendu
maintenant la question de est ce que nos
partenaires européens vont vouloir
poursuivre l'effort ou est-ce que ils
vont se désengager et donc il va y avoir
un travail de discussions avec nos
partenaires européens mais bien sûr nos
partenaires africains qui sont les
premiers concernés
si parler de l'influencé russe il nous
reste quelques minutes dans ce débat je
vais citer le ministre des affaires
étrangères jean yves le drian interview
au journal du dimanche ce week-end il
parle du groupe wagner la société wagner
se sont dans des anciens militaires
russes armé par la russie accompagné par
une logistique russes ils se servent
déjà en ce moment des ressources du pays
en échange de la protection de la junte
hinse poli le mal le mal vivre là les
termes de jean yves le drian antoine
glaser quel rôle il joue en ce moment
ces mercenaires je pense que le wagner
ça sert de leurre un peu je pense qu'en
centrafrique la france a eu tort de se
retirer il ya réellement donné c'est
vrai qu'on a un peu laissé le terrain il
y avait l'opération sans garris comme en
même temps les locales sont serval
françois hollande à dire on veut pas que
ça sera trop opérations de la canonnière
on se retire de centrafrique et russes
sont arrivés les russies fond de
l'opportunisme c'est un bon pas se faire
d engager comme les français du coup là
on parle bien sûr des mercenaires de
wagner mais c'est un leurre cesser les
russes qui s'installe sur l'ordinaire il
amène avec un objectif il est aussi la
laddh le général labadie bgd russie sont
en train de s'installer dans les bases
françaises au nord du mali tombouctou et
voilà où la wii parce que la france a
remis sa force mayenne mais les russies
s'installe au nord à les distinguer un
type ans on a ce que c'est un
instructeur est ce que c'est un type de
wagner au bout d'un moment et puis
l'ensemble de la junte les gens ils ont
été formés en russie je pense qu'on ne
s'est encore une fois on est il faut
voir grand angle une autre gamme
d'historique ça veut dire vous avez si
vous voyez les réactions alors moi je
suis d'accord c'est pas d'érection
antilles françaises mais c'est quelque
chose qui est comme si on était encore
dans la guerre froide pour les jeunes
cerveaux encore comme si la france est
tout puissant dans toute la région et
les russes bon vin par opportunisme ces
centres a fait qu'on parle pas du soudan
mais ils sont au soudan et là ils sont
au mali pourquoi parce que le mali d une
coopération russe militaires russes tous
les gens qui sont pouvoir du temps
modibo kéita moussa traoré si c'est pas
à eux c'est leur enfant etc ils sont ils
sont déjà
négociations on va terminer avec vous
bagayoko
c'est russie sont pour l'instant mieux
acceptée par les ont parlé des
populations locales qui caillassent les
militaires français mais ça se passe
comment avec les russes mais comme vous
le dites que si je sais pas si j'aurai
le rayon di sole it is poli le pays dont
ça va être un taux un peu tôt pour le
dire à mon nez mais moi je pense qu'il
peut totalement advenir de la présence
russe qu'il est advenu de la présence
militaire française c'est à dire qu'elle
est accueillie avec des hourras et à
titre personnel je doute véritablement
que la maîtrise du terrain sahélien par
les troupes russes permettent d'inverser
la donne stratégique donc cet ultra
focalisation sur la russie à mon avis
s'inscrit dans une approche assez
contre-productive qui a donner davantage
d'importance à cet acteur en détournant
l'objectif premier qui devrait d'après
ce que des autorités restait celui la
lutte contre le terrorisme c'est le
double jeu de la russie du reste double
langage dans les mots le double langage
qui à la fois lorsqu'ils viennent nous
voir nous disent mais nous sommes à vos
côtés pour lutter contre le terrorisme
et profitent de cette situation pour
effectivement s'implanter et si possible
nous remplacer c'est vraiment ce qui est
tout à fait dommage et qui rend les la
relation franco-russe assez difficile
entre autres parce qu'elle l'est au fil
des escalades en ukraine
il ya quelques jours qui était lui aussi
passionnant merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir d'avoir participé à ce à ce
débat je rappelle le titre de votre
livre antoine glaser le piège africains
de macron du continent à l'hexagone
c'est donc publié aux éditions fayard